in january nineteen ninety hundreds of
East German protesters forced their way
into Stasi headquarters in East Berlin
to prevent secret police from destroying
files the scale of spying had been
immense stacked side by side the
documents with stretch 150 kilometers
even today 5,000 people a month apply to
look at Stasi files on this vegetation
we have to process this information
because the people who experience
dictatorship are still around it's
important to explain how the
dictatorship worked the next generation
needs to know that so it's important to
keep the files available I dots of a
pinched in funding for the Stasi records
agency is guaranteed until 2019 the
Commission is looking at what happens
after that they are two guns with
instant access to Stassi files and
processing them are prerequisites for
continuing the important task of working
through the communist dictatorship and
that's a view shared by a majority of
parliamentarians so it looks like the
Stasi files are said to remain
accessible to victims of the
dictatorship and researchers